Good morning, everyone.
This is President Todd Ferrante.
At this time, I would like to call the Board of Education meeting to order.
I would like to ask our board members to identify themselves for the record as I call your name.
Todd Ferrante, present.
William Buchanan.
Present.
Katie Yannis.
John Andes.
Present.
William Gordy.
Elaine McComas.
Present.
And Donald Smack.
And now I'd like to have a motion to approve today's board meeting agenda and a second.
Motion by Ms. McComas.
Second.
Second by Mr. Smack.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Okay.
Now, I'd like to have a motion to enter into closed session for the following reasons.
To approve closed session minutes from the previous month, section 3-305B to discuss
appointment, employment, assignment, promotion, discipline, demotion, compensation, removal,
resignation or performance evaluation of appointees, employees or officials of whom it has jurisdiction
or any other personnel matter that affects one or more specific individuals.
Section 3-305B-9 to conduct collective bargaining negotiations or consider matters related to
negotiations.
And section 3-305B-10 to discuss school safety.
I have a motion to enter into closed session and a second.
Motion by Mr. Buchanan.
Second.
Second by Mr. Gordy.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
We are now in closed session.
Good afternoon, everyone.
As we reconvene this Board of Education meeting, I want to remind everyone that we still have
a quorum.
A closed session meeting was held today pursuant to General Provisions Article 3-305B of the
Annotated Code of Maryland to approve previous closed session minutes to discuss personnel
matters and discuss matters related to negotiations and discuss school safety.
Okay, so before we begin, my sheet's here.
I apologize.
I've got to get my story straight here.
So before we invite our pastor up for our invocation today, I would like to ask everyone
if we can take a moment of silence to honor one of our own, Snow Hill Middle School's
beloved Secretary Jennifer Ames, who passed away this last week.
Let us bow our heads in remembrance.
Thank you.
I would like to ask Mr. Taylor to say a few things about Ms. Ames, if he would.
Ms. Ames was someone that we all knew, although she spent her career and was from Snow Hill.
She was a fixture throughout this county.
She spent 37 years as a secretary or administrative assistant in Snow Hill Middle School, and
it's someone that we all throughout the county have felt the loss, and unfortunately she
passed away last week unexpectedly.
So I ask her services this coming Saturday.
I ask that all of you please keep her and her family in your thoughts and prayers, and
certainly when you walk in Snow Hill Middle School, if you're a fixture in the Snow Hill
area, you know what I'm talking about, but even those who do not walk into that school
on a regular basis, you were always greeted by Jennifer Ames, and certainly just as a
side to not make it the light side of it, every time I walked in the building, she was
the first desk in and she would say things like, come in here, I need to tell you something.
And I knew most of the time I better go in there and find out what she had to say, and
she would ask questions all the time, but just a wonderful lady, and the kids and the
community knew her, and so it's just so sad that we lose somebody unexpectedly like that.
So again, our hearts go out to her and her family, and please keep her in your thoughts
and prayers as we move forward this coming school year and the year ahead of us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Superintendent Taylor.
I would like to invite Pastor Mike Montgomery from Coastal Community Church in Berlin, who
will lead us in the invocation today, and please remain standing for the Pledge of Allegiance.
Let's pray.
Jeremy, Father God, we just thank you so much for being such a great God, and Lord, I pray
that as we all meet this morning, Lord, I pray that you be with all of us this evening.
Lord, be with us this afternoon as we talk and we discuss and we plan for the school
year ahead.
Lord, be with the students that are coming in, prepare their minds to learn, be with
the teachers as they go to teach, give them the words to say, give them the patience to
be with these children and to teach them what they need to learn, be with the administrators
as they plan and coordinate, be with this board as they continue to plan and coordinate
what the school year is going to look like, and be with all of the people that are here
today, Lord, who have their questions, their concerns, their ideas.
Lord, I pray that everything be heard and that everything is pleasing and honoring to
you.
And finally, Father, we just lift up the Ames family and pray you continue to just bless
them and be with them in this time.
Lord, we thank you for being a great God and we give you all the praise.
Amen.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
I would like to share before, as Mike is sitting down, Mike is a brand new pastor to our community
in the Berlin area and little do we know, but his wife was a teacher in the Pennsylvania
area and Mr. Cowder interviewed her and snatched her up and his wife, they came in, he came
in as a pastor.
We'll be joining our family here in Worcester County and we'll be at Shaw Elementary School.
So welcome, Mike, and thank you.
Thank you, Pastor Montgomery.
And I have a motion to approve the open session board minutes from July 11th, 2023.
A motion and a second.
So moved.
Motion by Ms. McComas.
Second.
Second by Mr. Smack.
All in favor?
Aye.
Thank you very much.
Mr. President, as a notation, since I wasn't here, I need to abstain.
Okay, let's make the record, show the record that Dr. Andes is abstaining from that vote.
Thank you.
And now I'll turn it over to the superintendent for the superintendent's report.
Thank you, Mr. Fronte, and again, welcome everyone.
And I can't believe it's, summer is closing fast.
I see a lot of teachers out there shaking their head, and I agree with you.
But my report today is really centered around our preparations to the kickoff of the 2023-24
school year.
If you can believe it, the next time this board education meets, we will have been in
school for two weeks.
Yeah, exactly.
But let's not jump ahead too quickly.
Our 2023 summer academics were once again widely successful, with students engaged in
a wide array of activities geared towards closing learning gaps as well as enriching
students with STEM and arts programs.
I want to give a special shout out to our STAT camp, STAT camp, which has been an incredible
opportunity for our middle and high school students to have truly hands-on, and I mean
truly hands-on if you're able to see it, learning experiences.
I want to thank our county for being a great partner in funding this worthwhile program
for our older students.
This week, just yesterday, we welcomed new educators and staff into our Worcester County
Public Schools family as we hold or as we're holding our annual orientation for this year's
hiring class.
Just yesterday morning, as I said, our current reigning teacher of the year, Dr. Jamie Regely,
and I were very excited to speak to our new teachers to welcome them and inspire them
as they join our Worcester County Public Schools family.
And in just a short time, less than two weeks now, all of our faculty and staff will be
returning to get our classrooms and schools ready for the return of our students in early
September.
And as you know, we start with our students the day after Labor Day.
I hope I can speak on behalf of the board up here that we are looking forward to getting
out to our schools for our first day tour to greet our students, their families, and
our staff.
We have done this for the last eight years and just had a lot of positive things happen
during that day.
It's a stressful day and it's a long day because we hit all 14 schools in one day.
Be sure to follow us on our social media as we cross the county and as always, we encourage
all our families to share your first day of school photos with us using the hashtag welcome
back Worcester.
And so again, it's an exciting time.
We're looking forward to get our students back in.
And I know we're going to have a great school year in front of us.
So with that, I'll turn it back over to you, Ms. Fronte.
Thank you, Mr. Taylor.
I'd now like to welcome our 2023-2024 student representatives who are joining us today to
provide their monthly updates from their schools.
And I believe this month we're starting with Tristan from Pocomoke High School.
Thank you, Mr. Fronte.
In late July, the successful culmination of the Summer Academy marked a significant achievement,
offering students a comprehensive range of opportunities, encompassing service learning
projects, driver's education, and litera tutoring in ELA and mathematics.
A notable highlight emerged with the future educators in the Made Men program, who received
three college credits through a collaborative effort with UMES's High School Teacher Academy.
Meanwhile, the commencement of fall sports encompassing soccer, field hockey, cross-country,
volleyball, golf, and unified cornhole has been promising, aided by free physicals provided
by the school-based health center.
Additionally, Pocomoke JROTC orchestrated a first-year cadet orientation camp, engaging
participants in activities such as drill, physical fitness, marksmanship, and had a
Q&A session with the leadership panel of senior cadets.
The summer allowed current cadets to participate in national drill camp and senior leadership
camps, encapsulating the spirit of growth and commitment within the academy.
Lastly, Pocomoke High School's group speak up was featured on the front of an MSCA magazine
a part of their action line section.
We thank speak up for their work.
We've got some exciting events coming up.
Today, our AP teachers are hitting the road with yard signs and yummy treats to celebrate
students who rock their AP assessments with a three, four, or five.
Pocomoke seniors are marking their calendars.
Senior Warrior Day is happening on August 22nd, a chance for the class of 2024 and their
families to gear up for a big year together.
We're also taking our new Pocomoke area teachers on a tour around Pocomoke City with our PHS
drumline, adding some rhythm to the mix and showing off our fresh faces.
The Pocomoke Back to School Block Party is on August 30th.
This event is shared with all Pocomoke Community Schools, bringing together partners, students,
families, and staff at Cypress Park to kick off the new school year with a bang.
And last but not least, we're rolling out the red carpet for our incoming Warriors on
Freshman Warrior Day on August 31st.
New beginnings are near.
We as Pocomoke Community Schools would like to thank the Board of Education and Executive
Team for their continued support of students.
Thank you.
Now on to Delia Holland.
Thank you, Tristan.
Neither the heat nor the summer have slowed things down at Steve Nicator High School.
Looking back on July, we had a very successful summer academy that included the enrichment
and academic programs of sign language and deaf culture, Spanish culture, world art and
photography, High School 101, and SAT prep.
We were just shy of 100 participants, not including dozens of volunteers.
And we had a 100% success rate for our credit recovery students.
Our summer theater camp was also extremely successful.
It was great welcoming our future Seahawks into our hallways and building their confidence
on and off stage.
Meanwhile, our school counselors have been busy finalizing schedules, teachers have been
in and out of the building for professional development, PBIS, PLC, and student improvement
planning, and we've had all hands on deck preparing our building for the start of school.
That includes our new state of the art weight room and a newly air conditioned gymnasium.
Looking forward, we have nearly 400 athletes working hard each day preparing for the fall
sports season, and we have our talented musicians coming in for preseason band camp.
We are excited to welcome our new staff members to the building, SAT test takers on August
26, and over 350 freshmen along with their parents, family members, National Honor Society,
and NJROTC volunteers during our annual Freshman Seahawk Day prior to the official start of school.
On a final note, we want to give a special shout out to our custodians who have all worked
tremendously hard all summer cleaning and preparing our school for September 5th.
We can't wait to see our students back in the classrooms and walking our hallways.
Now I will be reading the Worcester Technical High School board notes.
Summer seems to have flown by, hard to believe that new teachers are in training already
and that veteran teachers will be back in two weeks.
We'd like to once again thank our custodial staff for getting our building looking beautiful
and ready for the arrival of 554 students for the fall semester.
Our summer stat camp was a huge success.
In the three years of holding it, our numbers have climbed from 60 to over 100 students participating.
We are excited to welcome the staff of the NEST Early Learning Center to our building.
The program will service two and three-year-olds and will allow some of our early childhood
class students to do an apprenticeship.
It is very exciting to get this up and running.
Once again, we'd like to thank the Board of Education System for all the support that
they give our school and school system.
Worcester County is clearly one of the best systems in the state.
Now I'll be passing it on to Catalina from Snowhill High School.
Thank you, Delia.
As Snowhill High School gears up for the upcoming school year, we warmly welcome our newly hired
teachers and educational assistants.
With our new and dynamic leadership team, we are confident that this year will be nothing
short of exhilarating.
Fall athletes kicked off on August 9th with an impressive turnout of students participating
in various sports.
The band camp is currently underway and we are thrilled to see such a high level of student
involvement.
The ROTC program was very active over the summer with our senior cadets attending leadership,
aviation and national drill camps.
We proudly welcome 20 new cadets during the orientation week of our first year cadets.
Recently our ROTC program also made an appearance on the Blessing of the Combines event.
Our students marched in the parade and contributed to the community by running games and booths.
Additionally, as part of our Summerco Academy, SHHS hosted an outdoor academy that was run
by two of our teachers, Ms. Ashley Striebig, a biology and environmental science teacher,
and Mr. Jake Nathan, our communication arts and English teacher.
We had 14 freshman and sophomore students participate in the program.
With each week focusing on a different topic of the environment and traveling to different
locations on the eastern shore, after learning about all the different ecosystems traveled
to, students then completed portfolios about their experiences and shared them with their
peers.
Moreover, the counseling office is gearing up for an upcoming school year by meeting
with parents and students to finalize schedules.
Our seniors and their families are taking advantage of summer meetings wherein which
they can get a jump start on their senior year by accessing their schedules, learning
about college application and financial aid process, getting more information about military
and work ready opportunities after high school and more.
On August 31st we will host our annual freshman orientation.
Asing 9th graders and their families will have the opportunity to meet the staff, obtain
their schedule, tour the building and get an overview of Snow Hill High School.
Freshman focused mentors will be on site to assist their mentees.
We are excited to welcome our incoming freshmen along with all students new to our school.
Overall we are excited and confident that the upcoming school year will be one of the
best.
Thank you.
And now back to Mr. Ferranche.
Catalina, Delia and Tristan, thank you all for being here on your summer vacation.
We know that school is right around the corner but we appreciate those very informative reports.
Thank you so much.
Now it's time to recognize some audience members who are joining us from the following organizations
today.
Do we have anyone here, and I already see her, from the WCTA?
Good afternoon, Beth.
How are you today?
WCESPA?
Worcester County Retired School Personnel?
Thank you, Helen.
Thanks for being here.
Representatives from various schools, SIACs, PTAs, anyone?
Okay.
Now we have one recognition today, I'm going to turn that over to Mr. Tolbert's Community
Recognition.
Thank you, Mr. Tolbert.
Thank you, Mr. Ferranche.
Good afternoon, everybody.
As you know, each year we have a fundraising campaign for the local United Way here at
Worcester County Public Schools.
And as all things in Worcester County Public Schools, whether it's academics, whether it's
sports or whether it's fundraising, we always want to be number one.
So we worked hard, I'm proud to say we had a record-breaking year, a number of $67,000
raised for our local United Way.
Today we have Ms. Amanda Haley here with United Way.
You want to come up, Amanda?
And we're going to recognize each school and the amount that they raised.
Did you want to say anything first, Amanda?
Hello.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for having me here.
Thank you for having me here, Ford.
I appreciate it very much.
Pam and I talked last week, and I just want to say thank you for everything that you guys
do, not just for the United Way campaign, but in your community.
As a parent, thank you for all of the incentives and the enrichments that you provide to your
kids, not just coming into the classroom to teach, but all of the extra things that you
do in the weekends, in the evenings, and how you give back to your community.
So very much appreciative of all that you do as teachers and individuals, but also in
your support of the United Way campaign, and I wish you all a great and successful year.
Thank you.
Thanks, Amanda.
So I'm going to call each school up, and then you're going to do a group picture at the end,
Carrie?
Okay, thank you very much.
First we have Cedar Chapel Special School that raised $1,599.
Next up we have Snow Hill Middle School with $2,459.
Next up we have Steve McCarron Middle School of $2,660.
Next up is Chatham Elementary School with $3,099.
Pocomoke High School with $3,103.
Next up is Buckingham Elementary School with $3,532.
Next up, Worcester Technical High School with $3,904.
Snow Hill High School, $4,085.
Pocomoke Elementary School with $4,090.
Pocomoke Middle School with $4,500.
Ocean City Elementary School, $4,648.
Snow Hill Elementary School, $5,184.
Berliner Immediate School, $5,324.
Steve Decatur High School, $7,000 even.
And our central office employees, $11,729.
Thank you everyone very much for all your help and all your participation.
Ready for a group picture?
Thank you.
Thank you all very much.
Thank you, Mr. Stolbert.
You're welcome, sir.
Now it's time for individuals and delegation comments.
All individuals who sign up to address the Worcester County Board of Education
may do so for one or two minutes regarding information, accommodations, or concerns,
which may need future board attention.
Concerns that are specific to an individual will not be discussed in the open session
and should be directed to appropriate district personnel for investigation.
When you are called to address the board, please state your name and address for the record.
And first up we have Myra Biggins.
Myra?
Good afternoon.
My name is Myra Biggins. I live at 500 Maple Street, Apartment 15.
Pull your mic closer to you. There you go.
Just so we can hear you. Thank you.
My name is Myra Biggins. I live at 500 Maple Street, Apartment 15, Snow Hill, Maryland.
Good afternoon. My name is Myra again.
I live in Snow Hill again.
As a parent with children who have attended Snow Hill Elementary School,
Demo Biggins and a current student who attends Demani College,
I am proud of the education my children are receiving.
I'm excited to work with the new administration and staff at Snow Hill Elementary School.
Congratulations Mrs. Matlock.
I am confident my daughter will have a successful year.
Last year Snow Hill Elementary School was recognized at the Maryland State Department of Education
because of the academic achievement of the kindergarten students.
I applaud the Worcester County Public School District leadership team for accepting the pre-K expansion grant
for another pre-K 3 classroom at the Snow Hill Elementary School this year
because the youngest kids in Snow Hill need to be in school.
I want the county to fund the additional pre-K 3 classroom when this grant runs out.
I am most concerned with the district's plan to recruit and retain diverse teaching staff.
It is possible the student can go through Worcester County Public Schools and never have a teacher of color.
It is important for my daughter to see a teacher that looks like her,
who represents her culture, and gives her insight for her professional career in the future.
Thank you.
Next up we have Amanda Bunting.
Hello.
I'm Amanda Bunting.
I live on Exeter Road in West Ocean City, Maryland.
I'm also a firefighter paramedic for the town of Ocean City for the last 20 years.
I have two boys.
My youngest, Buxton, is just starting Ocean City Elementary School this year as a kindergartner,
and my oldest is entering second grade.
He also started when he was in kindergarten.
Today I want to talk about my experience so far.
My oldest has an IEP for reading and writing at Ocean City.
I was very worried when he wasn't learning how to read despite all the hours that we were putting in together.
That's when we decided to have him evaluated for the second time,
since he didn't qualify when he was four or two years prior.
It was because of his experienced teacher that she knew something was off,
that we knew we had to have him evaluated again,
and that he would benefit from the extra help.
The team that we met with was six to eight people,
which is a lot of people for just one student.
I didn't realize that much work went in to every IEP for every student.
This has completely changed school for us.
He's gone from being the child that came home every night exhausted and crying when we tried to read his books
to the person that has so much confidence.
He's been a STAR student twice this spring,
and he's actually also been a student of the month.
So that is just a complete change for him.
He's excited to perform in the school play now this year.
He's made lasting friendships.
So this has been a complete 180 and a big turnaround.
I credit his IEP team, especially Ms. Levin and Ms. Colgrove,
for their experience, their dedication to his learning,
and the nurturing environment that they provided for him.
He also has been fortunate to go to summer school for the past two summers,
and that consistency with school throughout the summer has been amazing for him
because he isn't able to read at home and to focus, and there's so many distractions.
So that learning environment that those teachers provide for him in school,
he just wouldn't be a success without it.
He works so hard, and now that he actually sees measurable results,
like these milestones that he set for himself that he can achieve,
his confidence is built so much, and I didn't expect it so quickly.
Like, when they set that plan into effect,
how soon that he would actually meet these goals and achieve it,
and just the turnaround is personality.
So that is his story, so thank you for listening to me.
I knew I was going to run over because I can't keep anything in two minutes.
So thank you so much, and I just want to share that positive experience with Ocean City.
Thank you for sharing that. Thank you.
Next up is Willie Brown.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Dr. Willie Brown, Jr.,
and I reside at 333 Winter Quarters Drive, Pocomoke City, Maryland.
As you know, Worcester County Public Schools has been doing an amazing job as a system,
as well as keeping a student center focused for not only our students,
the parents, but the community.
The work that has been done by the teachers, by the leaders,
and by all staff members throughout the whole town district should be commended,
and the work has definitely been completed with passion.
My child, Willie Brown III and Lydia Brown,
both attend Pocomoke Elementary School.
They are entering the third grade.
Willie, Lydia is entering in the second grade.
I cannot begin to tell you all how much support that we have seen from the school system,
from the community, and the outcomes has been goal-centric.
Not only have every student in the county, for what we see,
feel like the skills and the knowledge that was gained throughout the school year has been successful,
but we also want to keep the system performing at a high level,
as we recruit more staff, teachers, administrators, retain the best teachers,
and as we look at the highest priority for funding resources.
I am hopeful that as more demands come about the Maryland Blueprint,
that we maintain the small class sizes and the quality of education that make the system so special.
I want to conclude by saying sincerely thank you for your efforts at Washington County Public School.
Thank you.
Next up, Laura Charle.
Good afternoon.
My name is Laura Charle.
I live on Juneway Lane in Ocean Pines, and I have a first grader at Shell Elementary,
and he has special needs.
He has an IEP.
He has autism in addition to other special needs.
We've taken him to many medical professionals.
He's a conundrum to them.
We've gone down lots of different avenues trying to figure it out,
and medical professionals, they kind of said we're going to stop trying to figure him out.
But the people who have not stopped trying figuring out my son are the teachers at Shell Elementary.
And his IEP team, they never stop trying,
and they have had him meet so many milestones and so many breakthroughs,
and they're just, they're like my family now.
And the thing that I wanted to point out today is that when I heard that Summer Academy was going to be cut from Shell,
I cried, like ugly cried.
He thrives in the smaller classes there, and he thrives year-round with the team that he has,
but Summer Academy is really special for him.
And routine is very, very important to him.
Oh, my goodness.
And if he qualifies for ESY next year, which he probably will,
it won't be the same if it's not at Shell.
He'll be at a different school.
He'll be longer bus ride, different teachers likely,
and it's going to disrupt his learning and his progress,
and we need that time in the summer.
And I know I'm not the only family that's going to say this,
so let me speak for all those families that want Summer Academy at Shell to continue,
and the other schools that it's going to be cut from.
It's so important.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Next up is Megan Seiler.
My name is Megan Seiler.
I live on Franklin Avenue in Berlin.
I also teach at Stephen Decatur High School.
When negotiations were complete and sent to association members for voting,
I was asked what I think a fair place to settle would be.
I don't know if I can truly give a fair colon number
because I don't have enough knowledge of how negotiations went.
I think the original 4% was too low, and honestly settling for that was hard.
I had voted no for that ratification as well.
In the long term, every year we get slighted on cola is another ding to my retirement.
In the short term, it's a battle between low colas and high inflation.
It's deciding between buying a full grocery load of food or filling up my gas.
It's relying on community donations to make my classroom
and instruction inviting for my students.
It's holding my breath between paychecks as I try not to let my daughter
see my stress and sadness when I tell her we don't have the money right now.
The bonus, though nice, is truly just a bonus.
It would not help my lifelong earnings, nor will it help negotiations in the spring.
My next year's negotiations are based off my salary, not my salary plus a bonus.
Even the mandate of $60,000 for first-year teachers isn't much.
I always check up when I think of my daughter.
Take a deep breath, you're okay.
With inflation, that $60,000 in 2026 isn't the $60,000 we're talking about today.
I fear we will always be the lowest paid in the state, but how did we get here?
We didn't used to be like this.
The financial situation of this county needs to be addressed locally and higher.
I know everyone says the funding formula can't be changed.
Since May, I personally have written to or spoken to Senator Mary Beth Carroza,
multiple county commissioners, and members of the board present here today.
It seems that no one wants to work with anyone outside their group
with someone on the front line.
Is that how it should be?
I'm going to have to skip, but I'm just tired of the secretness of education and funding.
We are not allowed information until decisions are made.
I feel like a pawn with no knowledge of how we got where we are and where we're going.
Thank you.
Mary Hathaway?
Good afternoon.
My name is Mary Malone Hathaway.
I live on Camelot Circle in Ocean Pines, Maryland.
Like Megan, I'm a single mom, and I am a very proud teacher in Worcester County Public Schools.
I've been a teacher at Stephen Decatur High School for 12 years.
I'm also a product of Worcester County Public Schools from Shaw Elementary,
although it looks a little bit different now,
up through Stephen Decatur High School, or Superintendent Taylor, you were my principal.
I have been proud to be a Worcester County student,
and when I decided I wanted to become a teacher, this was the only place I wanted to make a home.
But I'm not here today to talk about myself as a teacher.
I'm here as a concerned parent.
When I decided to form a family, this is where I wanted my daughter to go to school.
I wanted my daughter to have the amazing experiences that the other people before me have spoken about.
I wanted her to have the educational benefits that I received from Worcester County Public Schools.
I wanted to know that when my daughter graduated, that her diploma would carry weight,
and that when she went out into the world, she would have the skills that Worcester County Public Schools provided her with.
However, due to recent cuts in programs and decisions that have been made in this county,
I am starting to be concerned about what my daughter's education looks like.
She starts kindergarten in two short weeks, and despite thriving last year at Pre-K4 at Chow Elementary School,
I'm nervous what the next 12 years look like for her.
Not only for myself in the bottom line, but what that means for opportunities for her moving forward,
whether it's after school programs for enrichment, or God forbid she needs some remediation or stay after with a teacher,
those opportunities may not be there for her.
I am urging you, as we move forward, to, as Megan said, come together and work together
and think about all of our students, much more than dollars and cents on a line item budget.
But think about their futures.
Worcester County has always been an incredible place to go to school, and I am proud to be part of that.
As I see my wonderful students sitting here in front of me today, I just want my own daughter to have that same opportunity.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Applause
Christina Cosgrove
Hi, Christina Cosgrove. I live at 378 Schooner Lane in Berlin.
I came here today to ask the question, what is a teacher worth?
Everyone seems to have an opinion.
As a teacher, but more importantly, as a parent to five Worcester County public school students,
I am most interested in what is a Worcester County teacher worth.
So I decided to go right to the source.
I've collected 14 voices, one from every school in this county,
to illustrate the way our teachers go above and beyond every day for our children.
I will not have time to share them all, but I wanted to share a few.
Worcester County has a teacher who dresses up as an old granny,
complete with nightgown, rocking chair, and slippers,
teaching characterization while creating a community that encourages confidence and risk-taking.
Worcester County has a teacher who encourages sending postcards from vacations
so that classmates can learn about the world from each other.
Worcester County has a teacher who transforms carpet time into virtual field trips,
that's so much better, using smart technology.
Worcester County has a teacher who embraces families
and sends home class news and school happenings in multiple languages.
Worcester County has a teacher who had a 100% pass rate on the AP language and literature test.
Worcester County has teachers who took a group of students to the SkillsUSA National Competition,
where Worcester County students took the top 10 in the nation, scored within the top 10 in the nation.
I could go on, but I'm being timed.
So I ask you to ask yourself, what is a Worcester County teacher worth?
What should it cost to recruit and retain the quality teachers that we need to shape the future of my children?
This year I will have a child at Buckingham Elementary School, two at BIS,
one at Stephen Decatur Middle School, and one at Stephen Decatur High School.
Each of them deserve the best, and I hope that in the future my Board of Ed, their Board of Ed,
will make financial decisions that show just how much a Worcester County teacher is worth to teachers, students, and our community.
Thank you.
Next up is Emily Gilman.
Hi.
My name is Emily Gilman. I live on Charleston Road.
I have three wonderful kids all attending Chow Elementary.
From volunteering, I get to watch the extra efforts that aren't always easy, but go a long way in the life of the school.
I have watched Miss Dale, our custodian, help a student open a milk carton,
only to clean it with a smile when it's promptly spilled.
I have seen Mrs. Phillips and Mrs. Saracola in the front office, as excited as children for their positive achievements.
I have heard EAs, like Miss Payne, offer to help when they have a precious 10 minutes to spare.
I have seen Dr. Andes from this board bring his dog in for a student who really needed a positive interaction.
I have seen countless parents deliver snacks, volunteer, and attend assemblies.
I see dedicated, dedicated teachers adjusting lesson plans to meet the needs of all their students.
In the name of fundraising, I watched Mr. Cowder willingly get cold water dumped on his head for an hour at Fall Festival.
Chow has created a community so caring, I find extra duties to watch more.
What I ultimately get to witness is alignment.
I understand there are frustrated parents and educators.
I have been a frustrated parent and probably will be again.
And budgets will never go far enough.
But everybody I mention, the custodians, support staff, bus drivers, parents, members of the board, we all have the same goal.
We care deeply about the students, the staff, and the future of this community.
There will always be challenges and different perspectives on how to navigate those challenges.
But I truly believe we are aligned.
I truly believe we have what it takes.
And this needs to remain our focus.
The students will not benefit otherwise.
If we work together and listen to each other, all Worcester County students will thrive.
And I can't wait to watch them.
Thank you.
Applause.
Next up, Audrey Winco.
My name is Audrey Windsor.
I reside at 8826 Old Ocean City Road in Berlin.
My name is Audrey Windsor, and I currently have two children in second and fourth grade at Buckingham Elementary School.
Additionally, I currently serve as the president of our PTA and work very closely with our Title I committee at school.
Along with my older brother and father, who have all attended and graduated from Worcester County Public Schools, I am extremely proud of the fact that we have been members of this fantastic school system.
My mother, Ginger Gillis, was a driving force in the new Worcester Career and Tech School, built so that students had a school to attend that they were proud of while being provided with everything they needed to be successful at the end of their program.
She was also a driving force in getting lacrosse started at Stephen Decatur High School many years ago.
This school system has always had a special place in my heart, and I cannot convey enough what a positive impact it has had on my family and I over the past and present years.
I've worked in our local emergency room since I graduated Stephen Decatur over 20 years ago, thanks to the opportunity to attend the nursing program at Worcester Career and Tech Center.
While working in the ER, I have the opportunity to talk with my patients and develop relationships with them.
And something that always makes me smile is when they tell me they moved here because of how wonderful our school system is and that they wanted the best education for their children.
I now worry about those families who moved here for the best education in the state and for those families who are heavily rooted in Worcester County as well.
As we continue to hear the news of budget cuts and lack of funding that will greatly impact these students and families.
I know for myself what a positive impact Summer Academy and the before and after school programs have had for my children.
As I am the first to admit they suffered academically during COVID shutdowns and it was those programs that aided them in getting back to grade level.
I know this year is going to be difficult, but let's not lose sight of the fact that we are still Worcester County Public Schools and we are proud to be here. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next up is Susan Ostrowski.
Good afternoon.
Susan Ostrowski, Berlin.
I am very concerned with the pornographic material that is lurking inside our public school libraries.
The three books I asked for a review, I read two cover to cover.
They are not self-help books.
They are books on rape, incest, oral, anal, and vaginal sex.
These are books and are very disturbing.
They're trying to make the abnormal normal.
All Boys Aren't Blue is written in my opinion by a mentally disturbed man who is raped by a cousin, loved it, and is trying to make it normal in everyday occurrence.
This how-to book was cathartic for him to write.
In The Kite Runner, which is actually a well-written book, it's not for children to see Afghanis rape street children on a daily occurrence.
That's not normal.
And on A Court of Thorns and Roses, I couldn't get through.
It descriptively depicts a child being sexually assaulted by wood nymph fairies, stripped of clothing, bathed naked, then having her naked body painted by nymphs.
Children are the future of this country.
We must keep them in the common sense, normal world, not the abnormal sexual occurrences.
I asked the Worcester County Public Schools to conduct three book reviews on the three books I read.
I promptly received a response from Ms. Sills, coordinator of the instruction.
In her email, I was informed, I've got no stake in the game since I've got no school-age kids.
I cannot vote until I own property, is the way I understand it.
That's not what a taxpayer wants to hear as someone who pays your salary.
Commissioner Karen Abbott addressed this matter last year.
She had a different outcome than mine.
So you need my tax money for who knows what, but I'm told to pipe down and take a seat.
Listen to yourselves. Is this really your policy?
This reply is unacceptable, and that's all I've got for today.
Thank you.
Kate McCloskey?
Good afternoon. I'm Kate McCloskey from Ocean Pines.
I wanted to share my experience with the book, the request for a book review policy as well,
just so everyone knows what I had gone through recently.
Last year, March of 2022, I had called the head librarian because I was concerned about
the amount of sexual obscenity contained in a particular book that was in the school libraries,
and Ms. Sills told me that there was a request for review of a book form
that I needed to fill out and submit, which I did,
and Ms. Sills replied in an email that the book review committee met
and unanimously decided to keep that book in our school libraries.
I was doing research on Maryland criminal law, Title 11, Subtitle 2, Section 11-203,
and it prohibits the display of sexually obscene items, including books, to minors.
The law defines obscene as items or books that include erotic touching, sexual intercourse,
sodomy, et cetera, et cetera, which this particular book had all of these.
And I was shocked that the committee unanimously agreed to keep this book.
It made me wonder who was on the committee and how I could get on it.
Since then, I've identified 49 books and counting that have come into our school libraries,
I believe, during the pandemic years, I'm not quite sure,
but they include sexually obscene material as defined in this same Maryland law,
and I'd like to note that some of these books include violent gang rape scenes
and pedophilia, sex scenes.
And I bet excerpts from these books wouldn't even be able to be printed in our local newspapers.
We're talking about content that's well beyond our rated movies
into the X-rated material that's available right now in our school libraries.
And now I hear that the board changed the policy, the request for a review of book policy,
where you're only allowing parents, employees, or students to now fill those forms out.
My husband and I are Worcester County taxpayers, property owners, and business owners
for 18 years. Our three daughters have already graduated from Stephen Decatur.
So while my kids are graduated, I care about other people's kids.
That's why I'm here today and why I come to a lot of these meetings.
So to wrap up, I just want to know when the policy changed and why.
And since I'm no longer able to submit these forms,
I just want to go on record to say I'm concerned about the amount of sexually explicit books
that are being allowed on our school library shelves. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next up is Pat Barberley.
Hi, Pat Barberley, Newark, Maryland.
I, too, have been reviewing some of the books in Worcester County
and struggle to get through them.
I've been married for 47 years, and I'm being introduced to things that I just didn't even know about.
I can't believe we're introducing these things and giving ideas to our children.
If my husband or someone else were to read some of the content to a child,
I think they'd probably be arrested.
But if it's done as an educational thing, it seems to be okay as education.
I agree with the comments made by Ms. Mikowski and Ms. Ostrovsky.
I'm a concerned taxpayer. I don't have a child in school right now.
But I feel that I should have the opportunity to comment and ask for a review of these books.
I hope that the board members that are sitting up here are reading these books that we're talking about.
If you haven't, you should. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next up is Tristan Melvin.
Hello. Thank you. I'm Tristan Melvin.
I'm from Pocomoke, 561 Ocean Highway.
First, I'd like to commend those who came and spoke for themselves and for others.
Due to recent events, I found myself before you all today.
I am Tristan Melvin, student at Pocomoke High School and student board representative for the Worcester County Board of Education.
Though I hold these titles, I am here to speak as more than a student, more than a representative.
I'm here to speak as a human, as an equal to you all.
While serving my time on the board, I've already experienced the ugly side of the education system.
I've seen hate, bigotry, and exclusion all within the community we live in and cherish dearly,
not from the Board of Education, from people outside.
Principal Jennifer Rain of Pocomoke High School has been more than a principal.
Mrs. Rain is like a mother, a friend, and a teacher in one amazing package.
But most importantly, she's an inspiration.
I turned to Ms. Rain after seeing the hate spread around our community,
and I saw she was battling the negativity with inclusivity and love for all students.
It's been brought to my attention that as of late, Jennifer Rain and all of Pocomoke High School,
especially the wonderful club of Speak Up, has been under attack.
And I'm here to ask respectfully that we just allow others to be free.
Inclusivity, intersectionality, and diversity is not harming anybody.
And the one spreading those values is the one administrator that deserves and has been awarded for her work.
Jennifer Rain, Pocomoke High School, and Speak Up aren't going anywhere anytime soon,
so please find it in your hearts to accept diversity and inclusion.
Because if you care for the students of Worcester County, you know that's what's best for them.
There are bigger issues than inclusivity. We should not be concerned about gaining a flag policy.
We should concern ourselves with the real things and people providing educational disruption.
Not a flag, not a book. Some books are not the issue. You might be.
And remember, this is a student saying this. I am someone's kid. This is what I believe.
Please get a student perspective before concerning.
Some traumatic experiences must be heard. Stop silencing trauma-instilled voices. Stop silencing voices at all.
I commend Jennifer Rain, my principal and my biggest mentor. So much love to her.
Please continue to Speak Up for yourself and others. That's all Speak Up teaches.
Not the conspiracies some have created in their head.
Thank you.
Just a quick comment, Mrs. Strasky and Ms. McCloskey.
I'll make sure that you, we have not changed the policy.
But I'll make sure that you'll get a copy of that policy e-mailed to you so that you can review it.
Okay?
You're welcome.
Okay. Moving forward. Thank everybody for their comments.
Moving forward, I'm going to turn it over to Dr. Annette Wallace for our international field trip request.
Good afternoon. I'd like to welcome Mr. Philip Cropper this morning from Wister Technical High School who has a presentation.
All right.
I'm Philip Cropper from Wister Technical High School. Everybody knows me as Chef Cropper.
So I was reached out by Chuck Wallace from MSDE last October.
There's a thing called Sister Cities in Maryland, which I just learned about.
And there's five different sister cities.
One is in Lille, France, which is in northern France near, this is just playing nonstop, near Belgium.
And they reached out to MSDE and said, we want a Maryland high school to do an exchange with us.
So Chuck Wallace reached out to me and said, you are an exemplar ACF culinary arts program.
Could you please, you know, reach out and look into this?
Is it something that you would be interested in doing?
And I said, certainly we would love to be part of it if we could.
And here we are today.
So after about a year of meetings back and forth, most of them virtual with the Department of Commerce, MSDE, and with the dean from the school in France.
Here we are with this presentation.
He's a really good chef.
I had it all set up.
I don't know why it's not working.
All right.
There we go.
There you go.
I now have an assistant.
Perfect.
So the idea is to have eight students in grades 11 through 12 who are enrolled in the culinary and pastry arts program at Wister Technical High School to go to France for 10 days.
And then students from France come here for 10 days.
So the way it would work is we would have students come to us first.
It would be eight students, two adults.
They would spend a total of 10 days, five roughly in school with the students.
It would be a complete exchange.
And the rest of the time would be two days of transportation, one here and one back, and then seeing other cities and landmarks in the area and how they tie together.
The average cost would be about $2,500 per student.
We're coming up with that fee from passports and airfare because the students would actually be housed in a hotel there that's owned by the school.
And here we have a local hotel in Ocean City, the sea bay, that has offered to house the students from France.
Originally, we wanted to do an exchange where students would live with other students.
But we thought just it might be a little bit better and safer to be in a hotel than with other families.
Yeah, the next one.
All right.
So a little it's basically in the northern France.
It's about about an hour train ride to Paris.
So we can go right into Belgium.
It's a culinary hub in France.
The school that's there, they're called colleges, but it's actually a high school, has about 560 kids.
You can go to the next one and 250 apprentices.
So there are about two years, two to three years ahead of us with the apprenticeship program, which we just kicked off last year.
And the school is mainly a hospitality and culinary arts school.
So I wanted with us being the first time I wanted them to come to us first to kind of see what we're getting into.
Have a week in between so we can kind of work out any bugs that we might need to.
And then we would go over to France for for the 10 days.
We talked about where the students would say they're going to explore, eat, network, learn.
They're also going to learn five days in class and then two days of traveling.
And we're going to have round the clock safety.
So what this means is 24-7 bilingual dean, instructor on call.
We're going to have student travel insurance.
The cost of the student travel insurance is as low as about one hundred dollars per student.
And that's through a second party agency.
That's through MSCE phone tree and mobile tracking.
We're going to have MSCE State Department travel advisories and updates the whole time.
Chaperone ratio is one to four, which county policy is one to ten for out of county.
And then we have an agreement between MSCE, Little France and the State Department of Commerce.
We're going to do a project.
So we're going to do a written component where the kids are going to have to write an essay, PowerPoint or Prezi.
And then they're also going to have to do an oral presentation so we can include the whole student body of the program of 36 kids.
But we need to limit it down to just eight for feasibility of travel.
And then just some pictures to finish. That's it.
So that's our proposal. We're looking to do it late March, early spring.
Or early April. I want to try to avoid winter weather and snow delays.
But I want to get in before all the spring issues of, you know, graduations and sports and award ceremonies.
So it's all still up in the air right now. We do have a contract.
I included a copy of that with the board documents.
I have not signed the contract yet because I wanted approval before we did it.
But once if this gets approved, then we're going to move forward in October with another meeting with all parties involved to get it planned for the fall.
Okay. Or the spring.
So does Mr. Cropper seek your approval through the superintendent of this district?
Sure. Does anyone have any questions for Mr. Cropper regarding this trip?
Yeah.
Mr. Buchanan?
Do you have all the chaperones packed out yet?
So basically we would need two chaperones. One would be an administrator for the county and then myself.
So we could maybe have some extra funding and some extra board members tag along.
Okay. Thank you, Mr. Buchanan. Any other questions?
Mr. Gordy?
Dr. Wallace, obviously you have a hand in this. This is pretty new, pretty sudden.
What did your research show here? We're venturing into...
Yes. I'm very excited about it.
Mr. Chef Cropper met with me several months ago now and we talked about how to best move forward.
Again, I think this is another feather in our cap, feather in his cap, as if his cap could hold any more feathers, honestly.
He probably has one of the most of any staff member.
Because MSD each reached out to us and said, hey, we want to start doing this with the trades and we want to start with Chef Cropper in his program.
For me, it was exciting.
And Mr. Zimmer said he didn't want to go, so I thought you already had your administrator, but apparently now it's up in the air.
I thought he was taking me.
Dr. Phillips and I will fight about it, I guess. I don't know.
But no, I think it's a great opportunity.
I've been working with Mr. Cropper on the safety aspects.
I think that was a major concern for me and I feel good about it.
So I feel good bringing this to Mr. Taylor to bring to you all.
Any other questions for Chef Cropper?
How are the students selected, the eight students that would be selected for it?
So I get new students every year.
So my program is a one-year program.
You can take your junior or senior year.
So that's why we've kind of put it on hold until we get the new group of students this year.
Once we're going to have a parent meeting the second week of school, which I do every year to go over basic cost of culinary arts, the curriculum, what's involved with the program because of the safety aspect.
At that meeting I'm going to introduce this trip if it's approved so parents are aware of it.
And then we're going to have kids sign up by interest.
And then we'll have throughout the school year, it's going to be, you know, you're going to have to maintain your standards with your testing.
You're going to have to keep your grade up.
You're going to have to help with the activities to be able to qualify to go on the trip.
And then if we don't have enough students from this year, we're going to go back to students that completed last year as a junior that's now a senior in the county,
and ask them if they're interested in going on the trip.
And then as far as funding, I mean, we did a pop-up booth at the Berlin Peach Festival just two weeks ago and we did $3,800 in one day.
So, I mean, we have a lot of community support.
You know, I don't think we're going to have a problem there with funding the trip aspect of it.
Should this get approved, though, we are accepting donations today.
So we will take cash or check or Phil and I both have Venmo.
We're always taking money.
And the nice thing is when I said MSE, I said, why are you guys coming to us when there's other schools across the bridge?
And the nice thing about Worcester Tech Culinary is we are an ACF accredited program through the Maricopa Culinary Federation.
And we are one of three programs in the state of Maryland to be dual accredited.
And we're one of two to be an exemplar program in the state of Maryland.
Sounds great.
So do I have any other questions for Chef Cropper?
I know I have a lot of volunteers up here going on the trip.
Any other questions?
So just a quick comment.
Please remember the lead time to get a passport now.
There's significant lead time to get a passport.
If you've tried to renew a passport, you know it's three to six months.
So just as a point of caution, you may want to think about if a student does not have a passport or an expired passport,
it's going to be necessary for them to start that application process pretty soon.
Yeah.
And we did.
I did reach out to City Hall and Ocean City because they do passports right there in the City Hall office.
And they said that they would set time aside to do all the kids at one time for us.
So can I have anybody else?
Anyone else have any other comments?
Dr. Innis, do you still have something?
No.
So moved to approve.
Okay.
So I have a motion by Dr. Innis.
First of all, a motion to approve the Worcester Technical High School Culinary International Field Trip Request.
I have a motion by Dr. Innis.
Do I have a second?
Second.
A second by Mr. Gordy.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Chef Cropper.
Thank you, Principal Zimmer.
So now moving on to special education staffing plan, I'm going to turn it over to Ms. Schwartz.
Thank you, Mr. Fronte.
And Wendy and I have no trips planned, but we do have an approval item for our staffing report for special education.
Through COMAR, we are required to do this presentation each year and seek the board's approval.
So I'll turn it over to Ms. Wendy Phillips, who is our supervisor of special education.
Welcome, Ms. Phillips.
Nice to see you.
Hello, everyone.
Hello.
How's everybody doing?
Doing great.
Yes, speaking to the right, please.
Wendy, talk right into it, please.
Hi, I'm Wendy Phillips.
I'm the supervisor of special education.
I'm going to present to you today a presentation about the Worcester County 2023-2024 staffing plan.
So each year I prepare a little presentation just to give you a little bit of information about special education because it's so in depth and there's so much information.
So you already have the staffing plan in front of you, I'm sure.
And here's just some information to help you.
So, understand.
So how is the staffing plan developed?
This is a year-long process.
It starts in September with child count.
So we, our data manager, counts all the students that receive special education services and their disabilities.
That report is sent to MSDE in October.
When that report is finished, I meet with finance and we go through every single employee in Worcester County and see if they are working with special education.
They are included within a report that is sent in May.
So we work on that report from November to March.
When that is happening, during that November to March period, we are looking at caseloads.
We're looking at teachers, students, new students moving in.
Any new request, I will meet with principals and then we meet with the exec team.
And then in May, when the budget is proposed, a formal request for additional staffing is also made at that time.
Okay, so this slide tells you some of the IDEA mandates that impact the staffing plan.
So all children are entitled to appropriate assessments.
That could be a cognitive assessment, an educational assessment, a speech and language assessment, behavior assessment, many different assessments.
So they are entitled to appropriate assessments.
They're also entitled to a FAPE or a free and appropriate public education to meet their unique needs.
We discover their unique needs with looking at their present levels and their cognitive and their educational assessments.
Services can begin at birth and go through age 21.
That will be part C.
Services can also start at age 3 and go to age 21, and that is part B, which is counterintuitive.
So if a child wants to stay on part C, they can get an extended family service plan.
That is goals related to family actions.
An IEP is more school level, and that's age 3 to 21.
All children are entitled to an education in the least restrictive environment.
This is a continuum of services that we must provide, and children have to have access to the general education curriculum.
This happened with the reauthorization in 1997.
Many of you probably went to school when children with special needs went into a resource room, and that's where they stayed.
They found that that doesn't work.
In 1997, when it was reauthorized, a push for results for special education happened, which is great.
Children also are determined to need SDI, which is specially designed instruction.
They must qualify on a two-prong approach for special education, one of the 14 disability categories, and a need for SDI.
Then ESY is also provided to children, and that is if a child is not going to meet their IEP goals during the school year,
they can get ESY, and we provide them instruction during the school year.
That is required.
Transportation is required, and they are required to have that.
Not all kids, but a lot of kids.
Child find is one of the guiding pushes.
Actually, it's probably one of the foundational elements of IDEA.
We are required to identify, locate, and evaluate any child that is suspected of having a disability.
When you look at the definition there, you kind of think, who is eligible?
Well, anyone that resides in Worcester County Public Schools is eligible to be assessed and receive services if they're determined to have a disability.
Also, children that go to private schools are eligible to be assessed.
So who do we serve in Worcester County?
We do a great job serving our students here in Worcester County.
We have 121 Part Cs, Part Cs in blue up on the screen, students right now, children.
They're birth to three, some are three and four, actually.
And then we have 753 active IEPs.
Our Part C is the largest it's ever been.
We are at the largest we've ever been in the history of Worcester County at this time.
So who are the children that we service?
Well, our primary disabilities, you can see that the chart shows the breakdown of the primary disabilities in Worcester County.
Worcester County has approximately 11% of our student population that we service with disabilities.
And the state of Maryland has 12%, so we're just right in tow with the state of Maryland.
And if you look at our disability categories, speech and language, SLD and OHI are the three highest,
and that is actually the same as the federal numbers.
The federal numbers, that's about 66% of the federal, the whole entire United States, and ours is 63%.
So Worcester County is looking really good with our numbers where we are.
We do have a larger amount of children with multiple disabilities in Worcester County public schools.
The federal number is 2%, and we are at 11.2%.
Multiple disabilities are children that have multiple disabilities,
and we can't determine which disability has the most impact on the child.
So that is a significant factor here in Worcester.
So we have to provide a continuum of services.
This is required.
Students can receive services in the general education classroom,
and that can be, the general education teacher can provide those services.
That is at the very, that's LREA.
And then we can also have, which the majority of our kids have in Worcester County, full inclusion,
with supports in the classroom, and those services can be provided by a special educator, a general educator, or an EA.
Then the next step, the more restrictive, would be services provided inside and outside of the classroom,
separated from their gen ed peer.
Then the most restrictive is a separate, public separate day school, or a special school, or a home and hospital education,
and we also have to provide these children related services within all of these LREAs.
So where are Worcester County's kids?
We do really well.
We exceed the state target of 71% for 80% or more in the general ed.
We're at 84%, which is wonderful.
You can see in blue the majority of our kids are served within the general education classroom,
and that's what IDA mandates, and that's what our state department asks us to do as well.
So what programs do we provide?
Well, we have infants and toddlers, 0 to 3, and that was that 121 cases that we have right now.
Itinerant services, those are services where people travel either to homes, daycares.
They also, parents could bring the kids into the school and receive services.
We provide services in preschools and head starts.
Of course, there's services in all Worcester County public schools.
We have about five kids in our RISE program right now.
That's our program for children with emotional disabilities.
We also have Cedar Chapel.
Nonpublic schools, we have to provide, if a child is determined by the IEP team to need a nonpublic school,
that would be a MANCEF school.
We have to provide them with that.
We have a secondary transition services work experiences program and parent support services as well.
So here's some numbers for you.
In early childhood, we had 167 referrals last year.
This is the most we've ever seen in Worcester County as well.
The process takes 45 days, and we had 167 of them.
And think that team had to process 167 of those referrals over our school year as well.
73 children, 0 to 3, are receiving services.
15 are 3 and 4.
And then 26 of our infants and toddlers are in the process of transitioning right now into our school age kids.
Our school psychologist last year in Part B conducted 441 evaluations.
That is a lot.
That is four school psychologists, and that means they had over 100.
Thankfully, we were able to hire another school psychologist to relieve the load on our school psychologist.
We had 256 initial eligibility meetings.
That is child find and private schools.
We had 64 private school referrals, 30 children transitioned from infants and toddlers.
Our special educators, the amazing special educators we heard the parents talking about,
they provided 10,172 hours of education services weekly last year.
118 of our students in Worcester County received ESY services.
That means they were qualified by the IEP team to receive those summer ESY services.
In our school employment programs, 19 students were employed for summer youth employment, which was wonderful.
And 33 of our students were employed during the school year through our employment programs.
So Worcester County also must remain under the 1% mandate for students participating in alternative assessments.
Some students receive a Maryland certificate of program completion, and some students receive a high school diploma.
753 students are receiving services in Worcester County right now, as I said before.
60 of our students are pursuing a Maryland high school certificate of program completion, which keeps us under that 1% mandate.
693 students are pursuing a high school diploma.
And I'm just going to open it up for questions.
Board members, that's a lot of information.
That's a lot of hard work.
Does any board members have any questions for Ms. Phillips?
Mr. Buchanan?
How many students do we have under outside placement right now?
I want to say, I just looked up that number.
I want to say 38.
Outside placement, 38.
Yes, I want to say 38.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions?
Yes, any other board members?
That's okay.
Any other board members have questions?
Dr. Andes?
Why do you ask me if there are any more questions than you look at me?
No, I don't have any more questions.
I just want to commend Wendy and the entire leadership team and the entire group of special educators, school psychologists, occupational therapists,
physical therapists, speech therapists, and everyone who makes a difference in the lives of the children that you serve.
So thank you for doing an outstanding job leading the program, making a difference for every single child who has a special need or learning challenge.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. Andes.
That means a lot.
And I would reiterate that part of the success of this program is the people behind it.
And you guys do a terrific job.
And it means a lot not only to us up here, but to all the families in Worcester County that you serve.
So thank you so much.
And again, if no more questions, this is an approval item.
So Mr. Taylor is requesting the approval of the 2324 Special Education Staffing Plan as presented.
Thank you, Ms. Schwartz.
Can I have a motion to approve the 2023-2024 Special Education Staffing Plan as presented?
So moved.
A motion by Ms. McComas, a second by Mr. Smack.
All in favor?
Aye.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Ms. Phillips.
I'll turn it back over to Ms. Schwartz for an update on the blueprint.
Thank you.
Rather than keeping my back to you, I thought I would do my report from up here.
So as you know, we've heard a little bit about the blueprint today, but we're still moving down the path of our blueprint and getting to know it.
As of July 27th, we did receive approval from the AIB, which is the Accountability Information Board, and we were very happy to hear that.
Out of 24 systems, 18 of them received approval, and that means that our 24 blueprint monies are released when you receive approval, so that's positive.
There were two counties that were pulled out that they had members of the AIB that were part of that county, so they abstained, but later were approved.
So it ended up being 20 systems were approved total.
Four were not.
Three of the four that were not, Calvert, Garrett, and Charles County, had issues still with MOUs that they developed around career counselors and the CTE program.
So their monies are going to be withheld until their MOUs are determined.
So anything in the blueprint plan can hold up your plan from being approved if you're not right on track with the law, because we know that the blueprint now is law.
Queen Anne's County had a different issue with their plan, and if you're following along, question 53 deals with by 2024, actually by the end of June 2024,
we had to have a 10% increase in our salaries.
Worcester County did receive that 10% barely with what our increase was this year, so we were approved.
Queen Anne's County still, they think they're going to get there, but have not confirmed it yet, and so their monies are being withheld until they can confirm that they're going to reach the 10%.
Again, we had to grow 1%, and we did make that.
So we're starting all over again.
As at August 23rd, they're going to release a new plan.
This plan will be much meatier.
Our first plan just really dealt with what we're doing and some goals that we wanted to set in Worcester County.
We were able to set our own goals for the most part.
Starting in August 23rd, when they release the new plan, there will be milestones, data points, objectives that the AIB and MSDE are going to agree upon that we have to reach at certain points throughout this process.
So the stakes will increase because, again, reaching those goals will also mean part of having our 25 money released.
So we are moving down that path, and as soon as the August 23rd blueprint implementation plan is released, I'll be happy to share more of that, probably at our September meeting.
But if you ever have any questions, reach out to me.
The new plan is updated with draft off of it on our website, so you're always welcome to look at that.
But again, we had minimal, minimal adjustments through both of our review processes with MSDE and AIB.
So we are in good shape.
The next plan will be due in March 2024, so we'll start the cycle all over again.
Any questions around the blueprint?
Before I turn to any questions, I know the superintendent has to make a comment.
Just a couple clarifying comments.
We made that salary range this year by giving a percent.
If we were not able to do that, we wouldn't have made that salary.
So I want to thank the association.
You'll hear more about that later today.
Also, I don't know if, I think the board knows or our community, this plan is not just something they get in office and after about four or five hours, they're done.
This has been long, extensive nights, and I want to thank many people in this room.
In particular, I want to thank Ms. Schwartz, who is the blueprint coordinator.
Most counties hired a separate person to do the blueprint coordinator job.
We did not do that.
Sorry, Dee, but Dee got assigned by the superintendent as a part of her job.
And so Worcester County, again, found a way around without hiring someone.
And I want to thank Dee for her leadership there.
I also want to thank, most of them are in the room, our pillar coordinators, our leads for the work they've done because there's five pillars to that process.
And again, extensive work.
And as I look around the room, there are many in here or some in here anyway who served on those committees,
either an overarching committee or individual lead committees.
And again, just a lot of work.
This isn't something what Dee's reporting out on.
That is something we got in the room.
Let's figure it out.
I can't tell you the number of hours that these people have put in beyond what they have to do to make this thing work.
And I know some of our staff sitting in here are shaking their head because they were a part of it.
So I want to our community to know, I want our board to know, extensive work is going into this.
And we were highlighted, again, Worcester County was highlighted for the exceptional work we did on our plan when all 24 counties were on the line and talking about it.
So Ms. Schwartz, thank you.
And all of you who served in lead positions and in committee positions, thank you for making this happen.
And as your superintendent, I can't tell you how much I appreciate the many, many hours beyond that you've put in to make, again,
Worcester County to be the shining star here in the state of Maryland.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Any other board members?
Any other comments?
Ms. Schwartz, Ms. Schwartz, thanks again.
You've done a terrific job for us and we appreciate it.
Thank you.
And that concludes curriculum instruction.
So back to you.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you so much.
Before I get on to administrative operations and Dr. App, we're going to take a brief five, getting some looks from my board members.
We're going to take a brief five to ten minute recess and we'll be right back.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We'll get started here in another maybe minute if everybody can resume their seats.
Okay.
And now for administrative operations, I'm going to turn it over to Dr. App.
Dr. App?
Thank you, Mr. Ferrante.
For the board, I have your August personnel exhibit for your consideration.
This month retirements, we have Annette Freeman, educational assistant, Ocean City Elementary
School, Charles Willie, head custodian, Worcester Technical High School.
Resignations, David Burnell Clark, educational assistant, Stephen Decatur High School, Melanie
Brant, educational assistant, Ocean City Elementary School, Tyrone Downing, head custodian, Pomo
High School, Mary Ann Fardelman, teacher, Stephen Decatur High School, Kelly Flora,
teacher, Pocomoke Middle School, Leila Fowler, teacher, Buckingham Elementary School, Olivia
McGee, educational assistant, one-on-one, Shal Elementary School, Mary Moniotis, sorry,
Berlin Elementary School, Christine Oberheitman, educational assistant, Cedar Chapel Special
School, Margaret Rogers, teacher, Snow Hill Elementary School, Sean Siebert, educational
assistant, Berlin Intermediate School, and Samuel Thompson, custodian two, Buckingham
Elementary School.
New hires, Kathleen Barocchi, educational assistant, Snow Hill High School, Dillon Bowen,
student two, Snow Hill Middle School, Sean Browning, teacher, Snow Hill Middle School,
Kelsey Carter, educational assistant, Ocean City Elementary School, Ashley Chaney, teacher,
Buckingham Elementary School, Michelle Leo, early childhood educational assistant, Snow
Hill Elementary School, Jesse Lupowork, educational assistant, one-on-one, Berlin Intermediate
School, Sherry McCormick, teacher, Pocomoke Middle School, Jordan Misla, teacher, Snow
Hill Middle School, Madison Mulmar, early childhood educational assistant, Snow Hill
Elementary School, Cheryl Olson, teacher, Snow Hill Middle School, Lanfer Otazo, educational
assistant, Cedar Chapel Special School, Linda Shockley, educational assistant, Bus-Aid,
Cedar Chapel Special School, Jaden Waters, early childhood educational assistant, Buckingham
Elementary School, Kaalia Westfall, administrative assistant to assistant superintendent, Central
Office.
Promotions, Lisa Billings, early childhood education coach, Central Office, Janiqua Johnson,
Judy Center Early Learning Hub site facilitator, Snow Hill Elementary School, Leah McGee, teacher,
early childhood at Buckingham Elementary School, Dana Noonan, administrative assistant
to assistant superintendent, Central Office, Latoya Purnell, Judy Center Early Learning
Hub site facilitator, Susan Redden, Title I parent and family engagement specialist,
Central Office, Ryan Severson, library media specialist, Snow Hill High School, Kevin Smith,
teacher, Snow Hill Elementary School, and Brad Vandy Mullenbrock, early childhood music
physical education teacher, Pocomoke Elementary School.
And one other announcement, no action needed, Jennifer Ames, secretary, grade five, Snow
Hill Middle School, deceased.
The superintendent recommends approval of the personal exhibit as presented.
Can I have a motion to approve the personnel exhibit as presented?
So moved, Bill Buchanan.
Motion by Mr. Buchanan.
Second.
Second by Ms. McComas.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you, Dr. App, and we'll continue with you.
Thank you.
Our next item, we have the ratification of the negotiated agreements.
The agreement was signed in June and last week of August.
The Worcester County Teachers Association and the Worcester County Educational Support
Personnel Association have ratified revised agreements, which will provide the following.
For the Worcester County Teachers Association, salary adjustments, a step increase in longevity
for eligible employees, a 1.14% cost of living adjustment.
That broken out, 0.75% was effective last April, 0.39% will be effective July 1st and
paid retroactively.
Longevity pay increased by $100, and we have a memorandum of understanding for eligible
employees to receive a one-time bonus.
The bonus is funded by amending the Essar and Maryland Leeds grant funds for that purpose.
For the support group, salary adjustments, a step increase in longevity for eligible
employees, a 1.64% cost of living adjustment.
0.75% of that was effective April 2023.
The remaining 0.89% will be effective July 1, retropaid back to July 1.
Longevity pay will be increased by $100.
We also have a memorandum of agreement with the support group for a one-time bonus, and
that bonus is also being funded out with the amended Essar and Maryland Leeds grant funding.
At this time, the signing of these signature pages will mark the ratification of the new
contracts, and the superintendent recommends your approval for the revised negotiated
contracts.
If the board does approve this, we have signature pages that we would sign now, and we have
the president of the teachers' association here to sign as well.
Okay.
Can I have a motion and a second to approve the revised negotiated agreements, the WCTA,
the WCESPA, as negotiated, as presented?
So moved.
Motion by Mr. Gordy.
Second.
A second by Mr. Smack.
I have a question.
Yes.
Do you know how many teachers voted for the ratification or how many teachers voted within
that parameter of voting yes and no?
I do not have that number.
Okay.
Were the, was the WCTA able to hear the concerns of the teachers who voted no for that?
Yes.
That is something that the teachers' association, that doesn't come through our office.
Okay.
However, I did hear from Mr. Ivory Smith, and he shared with me yesterday, I haven't
spoken with Beth about the numbers, the support ratification was, as of yesterday, 44 in favor,
1 against.
For the support staff?
Yes.
Okay.
While I'm happy to see that the ESSER funds were used to make up a portion of what was
promised to the staff, I am in agreement with some of the personnel that I've spoken to
who feel ESSER funds are not negotiated and were always assigned to the county by the
state, meaning that the Board of Education really didn't sacrifice anything in this negotiation
process.
I do still feel that there are unnecessary spending cuts that could be made for our teachers
and support staff to make them whole.
Okay.
I have a motion and a second.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Okay.
One opposed, let the record show Ms. Addis was opposed.
The motion carries.
We will now sign the agreement.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, Beth, for your hard work.
Thank you, Beth.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. App.
I'll turn it back over to you for school bus 7.3.
Thank you, Ms. Ferrante.
I'd like to invite Ms. Kim Heiser, our manager of transportation, up to address the board
for the purchase of a new school bus, and then after that she'll be asking you to replace
a bus contractor.
Good afternoon, everyone.
As Dr. App said, I do have two things to present to you today.
The first exhibit is to request permission to purchase a new or used replacement school
bus.
Mr. Dean Ennis, who is a contractor in the Pocomoke area, he currently has a regular
run bus and a spare bus.
His spare bus is starting its 14th of its 15th year.
And it's important to note Mr. Ennis puts a lot of miles on buses because he's one
of the athletic bus providers, and so he travels a lot putting a lot of miles on his bus, not
just coming home, home to school, school to home, but for other field trips and events
as well.
He is requesting permission to purchase a new bus, not to be put in place this school
year, but for the coming school year, 24, 25.
It is currently about a year to build and order a bus, and so for production timeline,
he's requesting permission to order a bus for the fall and have it for the following
school year.
So it is the recommendation of the superintendent to approve the exhibit as presented.
Can I have a motion to approve the purchase of the new school bus exhibit as presented?
So moved.
Okay, motion by Ms. McComas.
Do I have a second?
Second.
A second by Ms. Hattis.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you, Ms. Hager.
You can go forward.
For the second exhibit, we had a contractor notify me the third week of July that she
was going to be giving up her contract and moving out of state.
Ms. Kim Moore, who provides transportation services for Stephen Cater Middle, BIS, and
Buckingham Elementary School is giving up her contract.
With that, we notified all available folks who were interested, and we had a selection
process that involved a school administrator, myself, and the school vehicle driver instructor,
and we have selected Ms. Laura Lewis to replace Ms. Kim Moore as a bus contractor on the northern
part of the county effective for the 23, 24 school year.
It is the recommendation of the superintendent to approve this exhibit as presented.
Thank you, Ms. Hager.
Can I have a motion to approve the replacement bus contractor exhibit as presented?
Motion, Donald Smack.
Motion by Mr. Smack.
Second.
A second by Mr. Gordy.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you, Ms. Hager.
I will note that with all that unfolding, I've asked permission for Mr. Ennis to purchase
a new bus, but he's decided to purchase Ms. Moore's bus that is only three years old
because the contractor coming on does not need the bus that Ms. Moore had for sale,
so with all that said, that bus will not be sitting.
He is purchasing Ms. Moore's bus.
Thank you.
Mr. Ferrante, I'd just like to thank Kim for all the work she's doing.
Also, I see Mike and Nancy Donoway in the back, and I want to thank them for working with
us as the school bus contractor association.
We are meet and confer team.
They are two members of that team, and we had a great collaboration this year, and we
came to an agreement with the bus drivers as well, and they're going to be also receiving
a bonus as well, so we thank them.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate it.
Thanks again, Kim.
Thank you.
And now I'm going to turn it over for the memorandum of understanding between the WCPS
and the Worcester County Sheriff's Office to Dr. Annette Wallace, our safety officer.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Again, in your board exhibit, you will see a memorandum of understanding between Worcester
County Public Schools and the Sheriff's Office.
We have had a memorandum of understanding with them since we've had school resource
deputies in our schools.
We collaboratively noted that we needed to firm up some things and make our memorandum
of understanding a little bit stronger.
So over the past few months and specifically the last few weeks, we worked together on
a memorandum of understanding that we can both feel comfortable with.
And so before you is that memorandum of understanding, and the superintendent would request your
approval of the memorandum of understanding, and subsequently, should you choose to approve,
we will at a later date have Mr. Ferrante signature.
We do have one edit to make on the document.
So we will have Mr. Taylor's signature and Mr. Ferrante's signature at a later date on
that document.
Thank you, Dr. Wallace.
Any questions for Dr. Wallace regarding that memorandum of understanding?
Can I have a motion to approve the memorandum of understanding between the WCPS and the
Worcester County Sheriff's Office, and a second?
Motion.
A motion by Mr. Smack.
Second.
A second by Mrs. Addis.
Any discussion?
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I would like to publicly thank Sheriff Matt Crisafoli, as well as his Chief Deputy Nate
Passwater, and also his staff who worked.
And my staff, Mr. Sean Goddard, who's in the back, who spent a lot of time working on this
document.
So we appreciate their partnership and collaboration.
Next is a safety update, and it's going to be brief this month.
We have set up our next district-wide safety meeting for September 12th at 5.30, and those
in the community and within our school community who are a part of that will be getting an
invitation in the next day or so for that follow-up safety meeting where our communication
team will provide updates, as well as our weapons detection subcommittee will be providing
updates.
So that is coming up.
Our school safety plans are being resubmitted as we have moved to, and I love you guys,
reunification protocol, as well as a standard response using that program.
I know several of our board members attended some of our safety conference where those
things were discussed, but our schools are actively working on updating their safety
plans to make sure all the new protocols are there.
Any questions?
Any questions for Dr. Wallace?
Okay.
Thank you so much.
So now I'm going to ask Mrs. Sears to come up for a school system calendar revision.
Carrie, welcome.
If you'll speak into the mic for us, please, thank you.
Will do.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I actually have a very quick calendar revision, and hopefully the only one we'll have this
year.
So following last month's board meeting, we were notified by the Worcester County Board
of Elections that the presidential primary date was different from what we had originally
taught, what we were originally told.
That decision was made at the state level, but basically we are coming to you to propose
a change to our countywide professional development day, which is traditionally held on our
election days.
That way our schools that are polling places, learning is not disrupted at that time.
So the superintendent is recommending a change in our calendar to move the countywide
professional development day from April 23rd, 2024, to Tuesday, May 14th, 2024.
Okay.
Anybody have any questions for Mrs. Sears about that movement and that date?
If none, I'd like to ask for a motion to approve that.
To approve that change to our calendar from May 14th, actually from April 23rd to May
14th, 2024.
Do I have a motion and a second?
So moved, Bill Buchanan.
Motion by Mr. Buchanan.
Do I have a second?
Second.
A second by Mrs. McComas.
All in favor?
Aye.
Thank you so much.
And just so you're aware, we're going to be publicizing this out to our community to
make sure everyone's aware of that change as well.
Perfect.
Thank you again.
Yes, go ahead.
For high school principal, I know there's a high school principal in the room, and if
we have high school community who's listening, that is an AP testing day for board members
who are former school people who know that testing calendar.
So that is an AP testing day.
I've already had conversations with all of our high school principals.
We will continue to do AP testing that day.
Our teachers are going to be there anyway for professional development, but as you may
know or remember or may not know, an AP teacher can't be the one who gives the AP exam.
So we'll have teachers or proctors in the building that day, and our students will continue on
a regular calendar taking the AP assessment.
So that's all.
Thank you for that, Dr. Wallace.
I assure all of you that there will be no transportation issues.
Most of our kids at that level get to school, but if there is a problem, if anybody would
ask you, we will make sure they get transportation to the schools.
Thank you.
And now I'll turn it over to Mr. Tolbert for physical operations.
Yes, thank you, Mr. Fronte.
The first item is our annual budgetary transfers.
I'll walk the board through the transfers and take any questions that you may have.
Each year at the August meeting, the board is asked to approve budgetary transfers from
the prior fiscal year.
These budgetary transfers are part of our year in process and are required to amend
our final prior year budget to align with our actual expenditures.
As the board is aware, there are two types of budgetary transfers.
There's inter-category and intra-category.
Inter-category are those transfers between budget categories, and intra-category are
those transfers within the category.
In FY23, we had five categories where actual expenditures exceeded the original budget.
To properly account for this variance, the following transfers are being submitted to
the Board of Education for their approval.
We were requesting a transfer from the category of instructional salaries, $990,000,
and from the category of fixed charges, $516,780.
Also, as the board is aware, in FY23, the board voted to do a refresh of our current
student and staff devices.
This refresh involved the sale of our current iPads to a third party.
The proceeds from the sale were used to fund the final payment on the original Apple lease
and the first payment on the new lease.
We were requesting the board to approve an increase in FY23 budget revenues of $1,348,387
to reflect the additional revenue from the sale and also to increase the FY23 expenditure
level by the same amount.
Under the category of instructional support, we were requesting the transfer in $71,000.
This transfer to this category is largely tied to the expense of holding our commencement
ceremonies outside in our stadiums last year.
Under the category of textbooks and classroom supplies, we were requesting the transfer
of $1,348,387.
This transfer is a result of the refresh of our student and staff iPads last year.
Due to the favorable market for our iPads, we were able to sell those devices and utilize
the proceeds to fund the year four payment of the original lease and the year one payment
of the new Apple lease.
The transfer in this category is funded from the sale of the used iPads.
Under the area of student transportation, we were requesting the transfer in $492,000.
This transfer to this category is a result of higher than planned expenditures in the
areas of the fuel supplement paid to our bus contractors due to rising fuel prices, additional
time paid to our bus contractors to clean their buses due to COVID protocols, transportation
of our FIT students, and after school transportation.
Under operation of plant, we were requesting the transfer in $621,000.
This transfer is necessary due to rising utility costs and the increasing cost of custodial
and other supplies.
Under maintenance of plant, we were requesting the transfer in $322,680.
This transfer is necessary to address the increasing cost of HVAC and other costs related
to repairing and maintaining the systems in our buildings.
Also, the board is requested to approve the FI-23 intra category budget transfers, and
these transfers are within the category and are just in preparation for our year-end closeout.
I'll take any questions that the board may have on the transfers request.
Does anyone have any questions for Mr. Tolbert regarding intra or intra category transfers?
Any board members?
Okay.
The superintendent recommends the approval of the budgetary transfers as presented.
Thank you, Mr. Tolbert.
Can I have a motion and a second to approve the FY-23 budgetary transfers as presented?
So moved.
Motion by Dr. Andes.
Second.
Second by Mr. Gordy.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you, Mr. Tolbert.
Thank you.
And my last item, Mr. Fronte, is the monthly financial report for the month of July showing
salary expenditures of $2,161,983.77.
The superintendent recommends approval of the monthly financial report as presented.
Thank you, Mr. Tolbert.
Can I have a motion and a second to approve the July 31, 2023 monthly financial report
as presented?
Motion by Ms. Smack.
Motion by Mr. Smack.
Second.
A second by Ms. McComas.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Back to you, Mr. Fronte.
Thank you, Mr. Tolbert.
Okay.
And now I'd like to open up the floor to my fellow board members in the event that you
have any comments for today.
Satis?
After having conversations with fellow board members this past month, I am going to make
a motion to revisit and add one more night meeting in November to the fiscal year 23
calendar.
Okay.
I have a motion on the floor by Ms. Satis to add another night meeting in November of
this year, this calendar year.
Do I have a second?
Second by Ms. Smack.
A second by Mr. Smack.
Any discussion?
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it and I know a lot of constituents in the area appreciate that as well.
I guess I'm just going to give my board comments since I have the floor right now.
Sure.
But I just want to let everyone know this past month I was able to sit it on the first
day of the safety summit that they have yearly.
And this summit was one of the most informative sessions that I've ever sat through and I'm
grateful to have been given the opportunity to see the skill and expertise that goes into
the line of work of working with the sheriff's department in conjunction with the school
system.
The sheriff's office has many great men and women working every day to keep our schools
safe and it truly showed in the presentations that were given.
I was really blown away by that first day's presentation and training.
With fiscal year 23 negotiations being racked up, the start of fiscal year 24 budget proposals
are right around the corner.
And I have many concerns that I've been working with Dr. Tolbert with, or Mr. Tolbert, I'm
sorry, with getting all the information just so that I can get a better understanding of
the budget in its entirety.
Just so that we can all work together to make sure that our teachers, support staff, and
bus contractors are whole and considering what is coming down to the pipeline with the
blueprint.
We need to start having discussions amongst the board and executive team to truly understand
what the blueprint entails and I would like to start seeing scenarios for our budget to
include a budgetary pay raise of the $60,000 starting salary.
And then I'm also wondering how it works with the career ladder and if that's going to be
created and if so, will this discussion be made available to the public and allow teacher
input?
We need to be working together now so that the 2026 budget year, the community isn't shocked
when we are asking for close to a $32 million increase due to pay increases alone.
So I'm looking forward to working proactively in fiscal year 24 for, instead of, you know,
proactively instead of reactively.
In regards to the public comments that were made earlier today, I'm just, I know you might not
be able to answer today, but maybe we can have further discussions because I was reached out
to them very late last week in regards to the process of the book review process.
And I'm just interested if people are taxpayers, if they don't have children in schools but are
still concerned about the materials that are in our public libraries, what the method is with
going about doing that?
And like I said, if you're able to answer today, that would be great and if not, then we can
follow up.
Dr. Wallace, before we go, I want to make sure I clarify something you said before that.
Did you say $32 million?
No.
You said $32 million pay raise?
For the entirety of all of the increases with getting to that $60,000 at least minimum and then
whether or not that there is a career ladder.
Okay.
For the blueprint.
I just want to make sure I understood.
Thank you.
Sure.
I'll try to answer to the best of my ability what you asked and I'll let Ms. Schwartz certainly
contribute some.
So our library media specialists have been working on redoing all of our procedures and
working on a library media procedure manual.
It's been part of the procedure work that we've been doing as a school district.
The board was approving policies I think like two years ago and then now we're on the procedure
side of updating it and making sure that we have procedure manuals for all of our policies as
well as making sure all of our departments have procedure manuals which so our library media
services have done this.
In their procedure manual it denotes that the stakeholders, there was quite a few
inaccuracies and I've already been in contact with our coordinator of library media science
who's feeling I would say a little bit frustrated by the inaccuracies that were portrayed,
especially when someone sends something in an email.
So it's very clear what Ms. Sills has said and it was very mis-portrayed her message back to the
individuals who spoke today.
So there is specific stakeholders, parents, educators, students who can make a request,
however, a formal request, however, Ms. Sills did promise in the email and I certainly could
probably pull it up and read it verbatim, but that she would go back to her library media
specialist and have them just review and make sure that we followed all of our internal policies
and procedures around selecting a book.
I can tell you off the top of my head, which is a reason why it's important I think for educators
and parents and students to have a voice in this as well, one of the books that was mentioned is
actually on our AP English reading list.
So, you know, it's interesting just like I'm not a doctor, so I wouldn't sit, well, I am a doctor,
but I'm not a medical doctor, so I wouldn't sit here and claim to know how to do
cardiothoracic surgery, right?
So as educators, if you're not an educator, you might not know that these books are on,
some of these books are on the AP list.
I know one specifically is on the AP list.
So that procedure is available.
We can make it available to board members.
I know Mr. Ferrante specifically spoke.
So again, Ms. Sills did not say anything about a procedure being changed.
That is incorrect.
It's a blatant non-truth.
And so, you know, we would be glad also to reach out to the, I'll be glad to reach out to the ladies
or specifically the lady, but the ladies who spoke, I'll reach out to them as well.
But I will also send that procedure manual if anyone else is interested in seeing it.
They're certainly welcome to see it as well.
I don't know if that answers.
Yeah, I think I was just more, that does help.
I was wondering as far as if anyone is interested in wanting to do that
and they don't have children in the school, would they reach out specifically to the school directly
that the book would be positioned at?
Okay.
And I'm aware that we didn't have any policy changes.
The board handles the policy, but the staff handles the procedures.
So that's what they're in the process of updating.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I appreciate it.
That's all I have.
That's all you have.
Anyone else, Dr. Ennis?
Just a few quick comments.
I want to thank everyone who worked in the summer programs.
I was able to attend some of the summer programs events.
And thanks to all the staff and teachers and central office folks who organized
and led those summer programs for our students.
The stat camp was absolutely phenomenal, as well as the other summer programs.
And for many of our students, without those summer programs,
they suffer what we commonly call a summer slide.
And that means when you come back to school the day after Labor Day,
teachers have to do a lot of catch-up work.
And that means they can't move the student forward.
So I want to thank and commend everyone who worked in those summer programs.
I also want to thank and commend our central office facilities and maintenance staff,
who I know worked very hard over the summer because many of the things that they
postponed during the school year because they can't do something
because the students are in the building, so they put a rubber band on it
and wait until the summer to take care of whatever those issues happen to be.
I also want to thank and commend our school custodial staffs.
Our school custodial staffs do an absolutely phenomenal job.
You walk in some of our schools and you say to yourself,
this school was built in 1970? No, this school wasn't built in 1970.
Well, it was built in 1970, or it was built in 1996,
or whatever year it happened to be built.
And they do an absolutely phenomenal job in stripping wax and buffing floors
and cleaning desks takes a tremendous amount of time and effort.
And it means so much to our students and our staff and our families
when they walk into that school building and see you absolutely spotless
while taking care of building.
I also want to thank and commend our coaches.
I noticed the big sign, August the 9th, started fall practice.
And as a former coach, I'm glad I was not out on August the 9th
doing two-a-day football, although I know we can't do two-a-day football anymore,
but I commend all of our coaches who are out there helping our students be successful.
And also the band directors, because some are band camp,
we have outstanding marching bands in our communities
and I want to thank and congratulate them.
And also I just wanted to say to everybody, especially the parents out there
who are sending your kids back, all you have to do is hang in there for 20 more days.
If you can hang in there for 20 more days,
they will be on the big yellow stretch limousines
driven by outstanding school bus drivers
that show up on our doorstep so you can get a breather for a while.
So again, final comment is on day after Labor Day,
I can't believe this, but the class of 2037 will enter our schools.
I'll say it again, the day after Labor Day,
the class of 2037 will enter our schools.
It's just incredible to think about.
And the decisions we make today will impact their lives.
So we need to do what we need to do and not just continue to make the right decisions
for our students who are entering our schools,
our students who are in our schools,
and the future students of Worcester County Public Schools.
So 2037, 20 days parents, hang in there. Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Anies.
Does anyone else have any other comments?
Mr. McKinnon.
Thank you.
I think Dr. Anies kind of took my steam out a little bit in regard to stat camp.
Last month I was able to stop in probably after the first week.
I didn't get to make the last week because I wasn't around,
but Mr. Techwood is very, very impressive.
I was very, very impressed with it.
The cutting-edge technology that the students of Worcester County are being exposed to
is just absolutely phenomenal, phenomenal.
And it's the collaboration between the county commissioner's funding
and this program where they fund it, but we make it happen.
And we make it happen by the expertise of our teachers.
Because when I was watching them go through and work with the students,
it made me proud of the teachers of Worcester County.
I learned a couple new terms, glow-forge and laser printing,
which I never really thought that I would see that type of technology in a high school.
That would be something that would probably be in an engineering program in a college.
So that's my hats off to them.
The second and last thing is I understand the concern that speakers today
gave to us in regard to the summer academy and after school.
I understand the importance of that because when I was still in the classroom,
I taught summer academy and I taught after school.
And I could see how students reacted to that and how important it was
to continue that school day or to continue that school year.
And I think I've said this before too.
You've got kids in the summertime that want to go back to school
and whether they're going into an academic area or going into, in my case,
an artistic area, it's just great.
I just don't have any other words for that.
But to the teachers that spoke, I hear you.
I really do. I understand. I understand. Thank you.
Thanks. Anyone else have any comments?
I do want to make an announcement.
Last, it's been a couple of weeks ago that Vice President Buchanan, myself,
Superintendent Taylor were able to join President Bertino
from the county commissioners along with Vice President Bunning
and the county administrator, Mr. Weston Young.
We had a very meaningful discussion.
We talked about how we can get together in advance
and try to work through things in the future year.
And we decided that it would be beneficial for our boards to have a joint meeting.
And we will be planning on doing that.
I do not have a time and date for you right now
because our board just agreed to do it today.
It was a conversation Mr. Bertino and I had after he cleared it with his board.
So we will be getting together in an open meeting so everyone can attend.
And that will happen sometime in the near future.
And we will let you know.
We will make the announcement to let you know when that's going to happen.
And before I adjourn the meeting today
and turn it over to Mr. Taylor for informational items,
you know, I always heard about Jim Ahman,
who had been the board attorney here for 25 years.
He had been the board attorney here.
And I never thought I'd have the opportunity to sit at the table with him
when he was a board attorney.
But he filled in today for Ms. Stansberry.
And Jim, I'm happy to see you here.
Thanks for being back.
And now turn it over to Mr. Taylor for the following informational items.
Mr. Taylor?
Thank you, Mr. Fronte.
Just a few announcements today before we dismiss.
On August 28th, remember that date, all teachers returned to our buildings.
That's right around the corner, about 14 days maybe, 13 days.
All of our schools the first week have open houses or back to school
or some event for their schools or at least most of them to do.
And I do have some dates, and I'm going to run through them quickly
in case you want to take note or whatever.
But on August 29th, Stephen Decatur Middle will have an open house
back to school from 5 to 7.
On August 30th, the Pocomoke area schools will be all down at Cypress Park
from 5 to 7.
That's always a very neat event.
The same evening, Snow Hill area schools will be having everybody back,
and that's another neat event.
We're able as an executive team to visit both of those.
The Snow Hill area schools is from 5 to 7, and Cedar Chapel is from 3 to 5.
So again, looking forward to that event.
Buckingham Elementary School on August 30th will have theirs,
have a back to school barbecue from 3 to 5.
Also on the 30th, Snow Hill High School from 8 to 12 will have freshman orientation.
And on August 30th, the Berlin Intermediate School will have their event from 5 to 7.
Moving on to August 31st, Pocomoke Elementary School will have theirs from 3 to 5.
Buckingham Elementary School will have a 930 to 11 pre-K open house.
And on the 31st also, Ocean City Elementary will have theirs from 10 to 12.
Also the same day, Snow Hill, excuse me, Schell Elementary School will have theirs from 10 to 12.
And Stephen Decatur High School on the 31st will have their famous freshman Seahawk Day.
Boy, do I remember those, from 930 to 12.
And then that same day, Pocomoke High School will have their freshman Warrior Day.
So all great events coming, and the most famous date that I will announce to you, September the 5th,
everybody comes back to school.
So we're looking forward to, we're really back in gear now,
but we're looking forward to some great events as we kick off the school year.
There's a handful of teachers still sitting in here.
And I will say as your superintendent, I'm very proud to serve with you.
And I'm very honored to see the level of work that you do each and every day
for the young people in our schools.
And if you could pass that along to your colleagues as your superintendent,
I'm very, very honored to be alongside you as we take this journey each and every year.
Thank you, Todd.
Thank you, Mr. Taylor.
The next regular Worcester County Board of Education meeting will be held Tuesday, September 19th,
in the Sarah D. Thompson Board Meeting Room of Worcester County Board of Education Central Office,
located at 6270 Worcester Highway, Newark, Maryland.
The open session will begin at 11 a.m.
Immediately consider voting to convene into closed session under general provisions
Article 3-305B of the annotated code of mail.
The board will reconvene in open session at 1230 p.m.
And the board meeting information is posted on our website, www.worcesterk12.org,
located under board meeting docs.
And so I will, can I have a motion and a second to adjourn today's open session meeting?
Motion.
Motion by Mr. Snack.
Second.
A second by Mr. Buchanan.
All in favor?
Aye.
We are adjourned.
Thank you.